coming up next week in Brussels cloning
Mario Draghi and female empowerment
welcome to the agenda Edward Snowden is
a man who revealed the secrets of the
u.s. spy agency the NSA including
industrial espionage the revelations it
could become a thing of the past as
trade secrets I said to get a high level
of protection there is no real
definition of what constitutes a trade
secret there can be anything that gives
a business a competitive edge the tools
by which to protect them are also vague
the legal affairs committee will vote on
report to afford trade secrets better
protection protection that could limit
the freedom of journalists and
whistleblowers we all make conscious
decisions about the kind of food we eat
but probably a question you're not
looking to field is one on whether or
not you'd like to eat cloned or non
cloned food not a question that you need
to ask yourself perhaps just yet but
food derived from cloned animals isn't
actually regulated properly in the EU it
comes under the banner of normal foods a
type of food that is rarely eaten the
Agriculture Committee will vote on new
legislation that would ban imports of
cloned animals and food from cloned
animals follow the vote on Wednesday
catching up on your favorite TV program
is made so easy online but when you
travel content can be blocked but maybe
not so in the future better
harmonization of copyright rules is on
the way to make Europe one big digital
market find out more when a legal
affairs committee meets on tuesday it's
an age-old problem will women ever get
equality with men the women and gender
equality committee says rules on
equality outdated especially on the
discrimination of women in the workplace
men still and more than women and women
don't have to juggle between work and
family life the committee votes on their
draft report on Tuesday and don't forget
to look out for the President of the
European Central Bank Mario Draghi the
shine came off his super monkey recently
when he promoted a big sell-off of
german bonds after warning of market
volatility he'll be at the Parliament on
Monday where it's expected he also
discussed Greece and that's all we have
its agenda take care and in
the week